Okay, we've covered a lot of math so far. We've done fractions, we've worked
with multiplying, dividing, adding and subtracting them. Let's try something
new. Have you ever wondered why your skin cells get replaced? The skin cell's on
the top of your hand end up getting replaced. Eventually they die off and they
just flying away. You don't ever see them disappear, but they get replaced by
newer cells underneath the top layer of your skin. So here's what it would look
like for one cell to replicate. So let's start with one cell, and see what
happens. One cell is going to split into two cells. It's going to double. I have
one cell, and another cell. Then, each of these cells are also going to double.
This one will make two cells, and this one will make two cells. And then these
four cells will also split. Each one will make two new cells. So here's my
question. How many cells will there be after seven rounds of division. By the
this segment, you'll be able to answer this question. We're going to figure this
out using exponents. Okay, this is just one cell. This is before any rounds of
division, so I'm going to mark that off with a zero. This is after the first
round of division. I have 2 cells. And then after the second round of division,
I have 4 cells. And then, after the third round of division, I have 8 cells. I
know my cells doubled every time, so I'm going to use a base of 2. Okay.
I know I started with one cell, and that cell doubled. So I have 1 times 2.
Then, each of these cells also doubled. So I have. 2 cells doubling or 2 times
2. Then I have 4 cells, each of these 4 cells also doubled, so I have 2 times 2,
those are my 4 cells and then they're going to double. There's got to be an
easier way to write this. we're going to actually do this using exponents.
Notice that all of my multiplication has a 2. 2 is going to be my base. After
the first doubling, I have 2 to the 1 or two cells. After the second doubling I
have 2 to the 2 or four cells. And after 3 rounds of doubling, I have 2 to the
3, or 8 cells. And after 3 rounds of doubling I have 2 to the 3rd or 8 cells.
Repeated multiplication is represented by an exponent. It's very similar to
repeated addition, like, 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3. I know I have four 3's, or 4
times 3. We use multiplication to represent repeated addition. We're going to
use exponents to represent repeated multiplication. So, whenever I have repeated
multiplication, I can write the base. Raised to an exponent. So whenever I have
repeated multiplication, I can have the base raised to an exponent.